So let's look at the answer to
our simple implementation quiz.
If we issue the next access only when
all prior accesses are complete,
what is the memory level
parallelism we get?
And the answer is, the memory
level parallelism is exactly 1.
Remember that memory level
parallelism is about
having a load that misses and
gets sent to memory.
And then our processor continues
finding independent instructions
here in the hope of finding
another load that is a miss and
sending it to memory while
the first miss is still going.
What that does, is that if we look
at all the misses in our program,
we will do some execution, and
then wait for memory to respond.
And then do some execution, and
Then sometimes a very little execution,
and wait for memory to respond.
So basically, our execution with memory
level parallelism of 1 ends up being
the execution without the misses
plus the time to access memory,
which is very large,
times the number of misses we have.
With memory level parallelism,
we execute,
we send the request to memory,
now we'll wait for it.
But meanwhile, we execute a little bit
more and hopefully find that next miss.
In which case, we can overlap misses,
and hopefully we will
find more than just two.
So, in this case,
we have that the cost of each miss
in terms of memory access
was not paid every time.
We paid really the cost of
maybe something like one and
a half misses total, but
we satisfied three misses here.